the Golden Globes this Sunday on NBC and
only we have the honor of announcing
some brand new presenter yep our friends
over at the Big Bang Theory the stars
kaley cuoco Johnny Galecki and Jim
Parsons and also Black Panther himself
Locanda forever Chadwick Boseman will be
there Andy Samberg and Sandra are of
course hosting we just got our first
glimpse at how that's gonna go
tune in to the Golden Globes to see if
we talk about the elephant in the room
or if we've gotten it to leave by then
seriously there's an elephant in that
room Golden Globes Awards co-host Sandra
and Andy may seem to be an odd pair -
some - hosts together but their
chemistry was clear just three months
ago when they presented at the Emmys the
winner is lala land no don't say that on
Sunday all eyes will be on Lady gaga
where she's the frontrunner to take home
a globe for the Best Actress in a film
drama for her acclaimed role in a star
is born and the new year has already
been pretty incredible for the superstar
gaagaa kicked off her 2-year Vegas
residency at Park MGM's theatre where
she will reportedly cash in 75 million
dollars making over a million dollars
per show and on New Year's Eve Gaga
performed her golden globe-nominated
song shallow and gave a special
shout-out goes Vegas show has already
been a star-studded affair in the crowd
celebrity fans Katy Perry and boyfriend
Orlando Bloom Adam Lambert and Jeremy
Renner but no one had more fun at Gaga's
show than the Vegas Queen herself Celine
Dion video of Celine dancing and singing
her Gaga favorites went viral over the
weekend after the show posting this
image of herself wiped out on a
backstage stretcher so funny that's the
exact same thing that happened to me
when I went to go see Celine show you
lost your mind lost my mind I felt the
same way Selena gets you good for gaga
cannot wait to see her at the Golden
Globes
[Music]